[Music]
let's talk about cocoa you brought up
your lovely wife Coco who actually is
Coco and your team Coco I'm team Coco
and she's Coco so we have our own
special bond actually now there's a lot
of online discussion about her derriere
let her bite people talk about it
they're obsessed with it yeah people are
obsessed with her rearend then they say
that she must be enhancing I mean her
behind in some way we have some photos
here that we just show these throughout
the show occasionally a beautiful woman
by the way but what is why do you think
she's getting this much speculation I
don't know they thing to think white
women can't have butts I say if you
think white women can't have butts you
just haven't seen enough white women so
there's some I haven't seen enough women
what they actually people were so
worried about it date that she actually
went on a doctor's they were Sona gram
in it and looking at it it's like they
got a ballard to do an exploration like
what are you talking about they're
they're actually they're actually
looking for implants was that what they
were doing no what it is is like you
know when people see something that they
can't believe then they go oh it has to
be fake I say just take it as a
compliment
you know what I'm saying it's like if I
go to gym and I get in shape oh you got
to be on steroids it's like take it as a
compliment it's like you got something
to son usual and they can't believe it
so it's got to be fake but it's real I
told him she had implants I would have
blew them out by now trust me you know
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know and what am I getting out of
lying about it she told people her boobs
are enhanced she has you know got a
breast job but the butts real so get
over it you know I'm saying all you got
to do if you want to grow up but just
eat mashed potatoes and macaroni and
cheese but she's clearly I mean she's
got that amazing shape so I mean I've
got a brother that's eaten a lot of
macaroni and cheese and and potatoes his
doesn't look like that she's doing what
does she do I hope your brother's
doesn't look like that once it did
anyway what I'm curious about is she
must be in the gym all the time she's in
the gym she actually has a fitness
application on arm iTunes you can go
Coco's workout world she's you know
she's a fitness champion she goes to gym
out three times a week she gets it in so
who goes to the gym more often hurry her
her that's her business you know so she
works for it she's in shape god bless
her you know
but all the people you know haters are
gonna hate regardless my boy said if ice
could walk on water haters would say
it's because he can't swim
you know so they gonna find some reason
to dish
you